as a lieutenant pointed out if it had
just been a failure of communications
then that pilot would have brought that
thing up to the surface immediately so I
mean uh we can speculate endlessly I
hate doing it because lives are at stake
I'm really sorry
yeah
and a bit of utterly hopeless it's not
easy to get out of there I can see the
emotion there in you that this is
obviously and and indeed also for you uh
Yani um because Dr Michael I guess
you must have had a moment when you were
in a similar situation where you thought
you may not get out of it right
yeah more than a moment uh the better
part of an hour and being a scientist of
course I'm a professional Problem Solver
so my first instinct was number one
nobody in the cabin would panic